henry dimbleby who authored a major
review into the country's food system
and indeed was the basis for the
government strategy uh henry lovely to
see you this morning um we're all
waiting on tenterhooks to see what the
government publishes um
but on the basis of that which you have
seen in that which you have been
informed about
how sanguine are you
well i've seen the embargoed copies i've
i've read it in detail and
it makes progress on environment there
are some good recommendations on a land
use framework and on as a secretary of
state just said the data program
it needs to go further it needs to deal
with trade and it yet again ducks the
trade issue and there's no statutory
footing
on health it's not that
uh
it rejects recommendations it kicks them
down the down the road so it says
basically that the secretary of state
for health will deal with health in his
health disparities white paper uh what
is interesting on health is that they
have recognized that there is a problem
with the commercial incentives of
companies and how they're aligned with
our appetites i call that the junk food
cycle so all eyes now are on the section
of state for health and what happens in
the next white paper
indeed unless of course it gets uh
pushed even further into the long grass
once again i'm just wondering i don't
want to put words into your mouth henry
but it strikes me from what you are
saying that this this may well have been
a bit of a missed opportunity by the
government
well i think it's not a strategy as such
and what's interesting i i i mentioned
in the report that
responsibility for this is is spread
across government and actually this is
the third response we've had to my work
last year after marcus rashford's
campaigning for some of my
recommendations on food poverty those
were put in place in the leveling up
white paper uh they put in place some of
my recommendations on
education on making communities
healthier places and now they've
responded on some of the environmental
recommendations but it is a problem that
government finds it difficult to do what
is needed which is to create an
overarching government strategy because
you have these arm wrestles between
different government departments
wasn't the most straightforward the
easiest thing that the government could
do to to deal with better for example
you know hunger you know amongst young
people was to expand the free school
meal schemes uh schema as you suggested
yes so market the things that they did
do they expanded the provision of meals
into the holidays which was fantastic
and they expanded healthy start but they
didn't expand free school meals
and in the inflationary environment the
two pounds 30 which schools get to feed
children in poverty which hasn't gone up
for years is now worth a lot less than
it was so they have less money to feed
poorer children nutritious meals
and more families are slipping into
poverty and therefore need
need free school meals so i really hope
this is again another department it's a
department for education but i hope this
is under urgent review there because
that number that 2 pounds 30
needs to go up and they need to extend
who is who is uh eligible for these
meals because at the moment it really is
the cutoff is way too low it's lower
than in northern ireland uh and it needs
to go to go higher
again henry i don't i don't want to put
words in your mind so i want to kind of
dig down just slightly more deeply into
this but but from what you have been
saying i mean
we understand that clearly there are a
number of issues that that need to get
dealt with at the moment but
if they don't push forward like this if
there isn't as you suggest might be or
are you suggesting that it would be
better if food strategy was controlled
by one government department that there
was one point man or woman to push
forward on all of this rather than as as
you seem to be suggesting well dh are
going to deal with this particular part
depart from the environment department
dealing with this
nhs dealing with that what do you think
it needs to be controlled centrally yes
i'm not sure whether that's in one
department or in number 10 we have a
food system that currently uh makes us
sick the poorest neighborhoods die seven
years earlier on average people who live
in them in the richest a large part of
that is down to food it's destroying the
environment it's not sustainable in the
end our food system will change because
by definition it can't survive as it is
but in order to have the kind of the the
boldness of action and the courage and
the link and the join up it does need to
be coordinated more clearly across
government
uh just just one kind of a final point
if we can henry um were you surprised
that there wasn't a commitment contained
within george houston's strategy
to to greater environmental standards i
mean one thing that you were suggesting
was making it easier to kind of import
food where there are higher animal
welfare higher environmental standards i
mean the government seems to have
completely sidestepped that
well i think it's no secret and i've
talked about this before that there is a
bit of an ideological arm wrestle going
on between those who saw brexit as uh
uh being about just free trade and those
who saw it about bit about being about
protecting our standards and
interestingly there was a story in the
guardian this morning which said in the
previous draft that they had seen there
were much stronger protections on trade
that actually have appeared in the final
version
so it looks as if um
one part of the uh of the tory party
have won that particular battle uh at
this time
henry dimbleby great to have you on the
program this morning thank you so much
for being with us
thank you